this little beauty is the 4000 series
indexing valve from k-rain Dwayne Smith
here your irrigation product specialist
let's talk about indexing valves
[Music]
if you're not familiar with this type of
valve let me fill you in indexing valves
are a single valve that feeds multiple
water lines they can run up to four or
six zones depending on the model its
design has few moving Parts which means
less maintenance and a longer life span
the indexing valve can be installed
above ground in a valve box or directly
buried typically with irrigation valves
you need one valve for each Zone each
valve would then need to be wired to a
controller with an indexing valve you
will still need a controller and a
control valve or pump to turn the water
on and off but one of the great things
about the indexing valve is that it runs
on water pressure this means you won't
have to worry about running any wires to
it you gotta love that it will work with
flows as low as 10 gallons per minute
and at pressures of 25 to 75 PSI this
one's designed for up to four zones you
can tell by the four outlets on the
bottom here and here is a sixth Zone by
the way this is a 1 an inch and this is
a one and a quarter inch if you don't
need all those zones you will need a
replacement cam with the correct number
of zones and you'll need to cap off any
unnecessary Outlets to do that attach a
PVC pipe at least six inches long and
cap the end if you do decide to do that
at a later date you can always come back
and make that outlet available by the
way you do need to use multi-purpose
glue not PVC glue because this is ABS
plastic not PVC
okay to change out the cam first we're
going to remove these retaining screws
right here and this is sped up
we're going to pry out the current cam
and this is the cam that I'm going to be
putting in now notice when we end
there's this little stem sticking up
right here and that's going to have to
match this divot right here see that
as you slide it in this stem right here
is going to fit up inside the cam
once you get it in you're going to
rotate
counterclockwise that's important
until that stem and that divot line up
that
and once it's in place it shouldn't try
to pop back up on you
and then put the two screws back in
and this is sped up
once the cam is installed the indexing
valve will cycle through all the zones
in order after the water is turned off
the next time it's turned back on it
will start with the next Zone in the
index
if you're looking for an economical and
reliable solution to your irrigation
needs the k-rain indexing valve might be
right for you buy yours today on
sprinklerwarehouse.com questions chat
with one of our incredible customer
service agents on sprinklerwarehouse.com
they really do know their stuff and
they'll get you squared away get
everything you need for that next
landscape project from sprinkler
Warehouse a proud member of the Heritage
Landscape Supply Group your success is
our heritage sprinkler Warehouse
America's most shop sprinkler store
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
helpful tips tutorials and general
sprinkler instruction
foreign